[Music]
are you a lawyer with a passion for
legal research the luxembourg court of justice
is looking for
young talented graduate lawyers
and experienced lawyers with
qualifications in Cypriot Greek
Hungarian Italian Latvian or Polish law to
work at the directorate  of
research and documentation
the court of justice of the european union
interprets the law of the
european union and ensures that it is
applied in the same way in all
the countries of the union
the lawyers recruited carried out
analyzes of  court case
law and preliminary analyzes
of new cases
experienced lawyers will also lead
specific projects in the field and
participate in the conceptualization
and refinement of
legal research tools
the European Union workforce is made up of
dynamic multicultural and
diverse teams  we offer you
the opportunity to have a positive impact on
r the future of europe
the european institutions
guarantee equal opportunities for
all if you meet the
following criteria and have a
satisfactory knowledge of french
do not hesitate to apply for
more information on the conditions and the
selection procedure
consult the website the young
points yyuu tirek and rieuse points better
at ping europe together